this morning cbs news is projecting
based on the hard count in the state of
arizona that president-elect joe biden
has
won arizona mr biden now has 290
electoral votes and the popular vote
count
shows him ahead by more than 5 million
the trump campaign is still challenging
the vote count
in the closest states but the federal
agency in charge of protecting
election security released a statement
saying quote
there is no evidence that any voting
system
deleted or lost votes changed votes
or was in any way compromised the head
of that agency has told associates
he expects the president to fire him
according to reuters and politico
paula reed is at the white house paula
good morning
good morning anthony several advisers to
president trump tell cbs news
the president is increasingly aware that
he just cannot
litigate his way to 270 electoral votes
but they also tell us the president
wants to be seen as a fighter
so he can continue to fund refund raise
and pay down campaign
debts now last night president-elect joe
biden's new chief of staff
he did an interview where he laid out
the risks of continuing to delay this
transition
in his first interview since being named
president-elect
joe biden's chief of staff ron klain
warned the trump administration's
refusal to cooperate in the transfer of
power
will soon begin to have real impacts
we're in a covid crisis
uh right now right now there are
officials inside the department of
health and human services
who are busy planning a vaccination
campaign for the months of february and
march
when joe biden will be president and so
the sooner we can get
our transition experts into meetings
with the folks who are planning that
vaccination campaign
the more seamless the transition from a
biden presidency to a trump presidency
can be
but like his boss claim was optimistic
about being able to work with
republicans
he's spoken to some republican senators
some republican
governors i'm not going to go into the
names he has not spoken though to
senator mcconnell they'll have a working
relationship when
the time comes president trump's refusal
to concede is
among other things blocking
president-elect biden from getting
access to classified intelligence
briefings during the transition period
claine said he was encouraged by the
growing number of republicans
who say that biden should at least get
that access
including the president's allies like
lindsey graham and ted cruz
for the sake of protecting the country
you want whoever is going to assume that
office to be aware
of the significant threats because
because the first responsibility
of any president is to keep the american
people safe some republicans say the
briefing should wait until all the votes
are counted
or recounted let's finish counting the
votes and
you know there'll be plenty of time he's
not president right now
don't know if he'll be president january
20th but whoever is will get the
information
this morning china reached out to
president-elect joe biden to
congratulate him becoming
the most recent world power to do so but
it's nearly been a week since the
results were called
and notably russia has not reached out
to the incoming president
historically foreign leaders have waited
for the loser to concede before reaching
out
to the new president but as we've seen
president trump at this point appears to
have
no plans to admit defeat gail all right
paula thank you